I think anyone who knows dia knows you
know above all else just the level of
care that he had for everyone else you
know other community members whoever
they may be these are people who did
good work who use their time and energy
to help improve the lives of others I
think the main thing people need to
reflect on is you know how much impact
positive impact these people had on
society on you know bringing goodness to
everybody themselves I've never heard
you speak harshly to anyone and just
very genuine genuinely kind caring
person which adds to the pain they were
the sweetest people you meet and I know
everyone in the community could back